who is the mysterious character on the
train and what does his presence mean
for the next season of the umbrella
academy keep watching because this is
the umbrella academy season 3
mid-credits scene explained warning
spoilers ahead by this point you've
likely made your way out of oblivion and
found out that the world of the umbrella
academy is not what it once was seems
like the team did pretty well for
themselves whilst with surviving samurai
guardians dodging a world ending
kugelblitz and double crossing father
figures after facing off against the
sparrow academy with that team's version
of ben being the only one to survive the
events of the season it now appears that
the timeline has been reset good news
right wrong while alison hargreaves
hopes for a happy life have been
restored via slightly villainous means
her siblings have been hit with the
shocking discovery that they're now
living without their powers could this
be the end of the umbrella academy are
the hargreaves siblings heroes no more
so many questions and not nearly enough
answers have been left behind for us to
pick apart forget slowly collapsing
realities and sentient cubes this might
be the worst timeline after all not
content with leaving us hanging the
anticipation levels were turned up when
we were blessed with a chin scratching
mid-credit scene that gave us a dose of
history repeating itself not
particularly flashy in its execution it
nevertheless guaranteed that one of the
casts from the umbrella academy will put
in twice the work whenever the show
returns the only question is will they
get along or will tentacles get tangled
up in the process after the credits roll
were taken for a familiar ride ending on
how the season began we see a train
carriage similar to where ben's
biological mother gave birth to him
decades before the difference here was
that ben himself is on board minding his
own business without a superpowered
worry in the world but how can this be
as we just saw him storming off from his
new stand-in family as the show shut us
forward revealing he finally overcame
his attitude problem and carried on with
life
not quite as it turns out this isn't the
same ben the mild-mannered passenger
with his nose in a book is the original
umbrella's ben with apparently no
knowledge of the life he might have
lived had his ruthless adoptive father
reginald hargreaves snatched him up for
the academy this means that there are
two bends wandering around in the world
just as five suggested early on this
season before it was discovered the
umbrella academy's parents had all been
killed by holland odds are we each have
identical versions of ourselves walking
around out there living completely
different lives
now we have a timid soul who never
thwarted a bank robbery in his life and
another that would actively go out and
look for one with this small dose of
double trouble factored in what does
that mean for the other ben and the rest
of the hargreaves family well we now
have a spare bend to deal with there's
more than one way to tackle the timeline
first ben might not be the only one
we're seeing double of next season given
that the hargreaves weren't present for
the reset after being outside the
timeline that could make them anomalies
with no original slot in the space-time
continuum to go back to as a result
their doppelgangers might be wandering
around the world just like ben having
never enlisted in the academy think of
it like marty's trip back to an
alternative 1985 and back to the future
part two that sees hill valley gone to
hell with everyone believing he's in
switzerland it's a plot line that feels
similar to this year's season it's like
we're in hell or something no it's hill
valley although i can't imagine hell
being much worse
if that's truly the case with the
timeline repaired they may have been
returned where they left off just with a
different history behind them this would
explain diego and five being an injured
and luther smaller and much less hairy
that leaves us wondering what's happened
to his newly wedded wife sloan who
wasn't present like her other sparrow
sibling ben or why a reginald hargreaves
from this timeline appears to be more
lex luthor than a cold-hearted charles
xavier one thing is for sure we need the
fourth season and we need it today
tomorrow or at whatever point in time we
can get it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the umbrella academy are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you